NATE KEATING: All
right, hello and welcome
to an introduction to MLOps
on Google Cloud at Next OnAir.
I'm excited to share
this overview with you,
and I hope it will
be super valuable
as you continue to leverage
AI to transform your business.
First, a quick introduction--
my name is Nate.
I'm a product manager on Google
Cloud's AI platform, where
we have a mission to empower
every enterprise to transform
their business with AI.
At Google, we've pioneered
a huge range of AI machine
learning breakthroughs, and
much of this industry leading
technology underpins
the products
we launch within Cloud AI.
But at the heart of our
product decision making
is a focus on the
capabilities that will truly
help our customers unlock
new business value,
and so our Cloud AMP
platform does just that,
by providing customer AI and
ML teams the infrastructure
and toolset to help
them get more done
more efficiently and
more effectively.
Let's take a quick
look at the agenda.
We'll start with the definition
and overview of MLOps
and the core challenges at play.
We'll talk a bit about where
data science teams are today
and where we see
them going, and I'll
share a simple framework for
MLOps based on real processes
that we see in practice
both internally at Google
and from our mature customers.
And we'll wrap up with some of
the services you can leverage
today to get started,
as well as where
we're making additional
investments in the future that
will be exciting to hear.
So let's jump right in.
MLOps formally defined
might be described
as both a culture and a practice
that aims at unifying ML system
development and operations.
It takes both its name, as well
as some of the core principles
and tooling from DevOps,
and this makes sense
as the goals of MLOps and DevOps
are practically the same--
to shorten the systems
development lifecycle
and ensure high quality
software is continuously
developed, delivered, and
maintained in production.
But machine learning has
its own unique challenges
and different needs that
require special attention,
and so let's jump
to a slide that
may be familiar to many, which
is from the Canonical Google
paper 2015, "Hidden Technical
Debt in Machine Learning
Systems," the takeaway being
that production machine
learning is more than
training a model,
and that very little of properly
functioning ML systems is
actually model training code.
There are a number of different
technologies and processes
that must be in place to get
the most out of production ML
systems, and it's really this
combination and management
of these different processes
that comprises true MLOps.
A simple analogy might
be the assembly line.
Prior to the assembly
line, automobiles
had existed for decades, and
even years before the Model T,
Ford had something
called the 999,
which set the land speed record
at over 90 miles an hour.
But it really wasn't until the
assembly line was introduced,
which is also just a set of
technologies and processes,
that continuous, high
quality production
and delivery of
automobiles became
possible and inexpensive.
And so at Google, the
Cloud AMP platform
is quickly becoming the assembly
line for machine learning.
But let's take a look at
where most teams are now.
Most ML journeys will
look something like this.
As a data scientist, it starts,
hopefully, with a clear ML use
case and business objective,
and with that use case at hand,
you can start gathering data
from different data sources
and doing some
exploratory analysis that
helps you get a sense for
what the data actually holds.
Once you have a sense for
what's in the data itself,
and you've imputed some missing
values and normalized your data
or done some future
generation, you
can actually start to
approach the modeling
and figure out how you're going
to tackle some new experiments.
And so you would
manually execute
these different
experimental steps,
doing more data preparation,
more feature engineering
and testing, and then you
do some model training
and hyperparameter tuning on any
models or model architectures
that are particularly promising.
Last but not least,
you would be evaluating
all of these generated
models, testing them
against holdout sets of
data that wasn't trained on,
evaluating the
different metrics,
looking at loss curve stability,
and comparing those models
with other models to see which
one actually works the best.
And of course, this whole
process is really iterative,
and it's manually executed
over and over and over again.
You might begin by doing
multiple different concurrent
experiments, testing
out different ideas
and different architectures,
analyze and compare
the performance there,
and then kick off
new experiments based on what
you learn, until eventually,
you actually iterate
towards an optimal model.
And you'll be
experimenting, again,
there with different
hyperparameters
as you tune that final
model, until again, you
get a model that is
sufficiently performant that it
passes all of your tests.
And then, of course,
unfortunately, at this step,
you put it in
storage and throw it
over the wall to the IT
and operations folks,
and it will actually
be their job
to deploy the model to
production as a prediction
service.
And they'll ensure all the
necessary features are served
in production, make sure
we have auto scaling,
make sure we set up any
necessary deployment
pipelines for all the various
targets, which actually
may be in a distributed system.
And so it's easy to see why
that process is difficult
and why organizations
are struggling here.
First of all, it's
really time consuming.
The steps are highly manual
and are written from scratch
for every use case.
It's also inflexible.
Custom built steps
can't be reused
and are only understood
by the author,
and so every additional
data scientist in your team
or in your organization can
easily leverage all of the work
that a particular
team member has
done towards their use case.
And I hear from data
scientists all the time
that even they can't
understand the work
they've done six months ago and
leverage that for the future.
This is also an
error prone process.
You get issues like
training serving skew,
where the lack of coordination
between IT ops and the data
science teams leads to
unexpected differences
in the online and
offline performance.
Not only is this suboptimal
from a performance standpoint,
but it's also really hard
to debug and figure out
why that happened.
In short, there is
a high marginal cost
for model development,
and it really
shouldn't have to be this way.
And so let's lay out a
framework here and start
by addressing some
of the challenges
we saw using this framework
across the ML solution
lifecycle, and then can dive
into some of the specifics
and the details of
each of these steps.
First, our first box on
the left, experimentation
is absolutely crucial.
We don't want to hinder the
experimental process at all,
but want to lean into it.
Data science today is
still very much science,
and for most use cases, requires
a lot of trial and error.
Instead of cutting down on
the number of experiments,
we want a way to embrace
experimentation and let
ML teams track and manage all
their different experiments
they're running to make sure
they're confident in building
the best model.
Second, rerunning
training jobs when
new data is available or
based on specific triggers you
might have set ought to
be really, really easy.
We want a continuous stream
of new candidate models
to test out and challenge
the model running
and production to see if
it actually is better.
Third, models must be
properly tested, evaluated,
and approved for
release following
a rigorous audible and even
reversible CI/CD process.
I think this step
is really missed out
on by a lot of data
science teams today.
And lastly, for any model
running in production,
we want to always have a sense
of how the models perform.
This is important to
ensure quality and business
continuity, but it's
also crucial for getting
the high quality
signals into how
to improve the model
for the next iteration.
What better training data is
there than true production
inferences?
The dotted line
at the center here
roughly delineates the
training and serving
sides of this framework.
Building a world class MLOps
team and platform is a journey,
and from a maturity
standpoint, we
tend to see that
customers find success
by focusing initially
on the left hand
side of this framework.
The bedrock of MLOps is
reliable and repeatable training
pipelines, and so as we
go into the next section,
let's take a look at those
repeatable and reliable
training pipelines.
First, we transform the
previously manual steps
of ML experimentation
into a reusable pipeline.
You implement an orchestrated
experiment of various steps
as a pipeline, which can be
executed in its entirety,
and which allows you to
iterate by changing some
of the configurations to
point to different data
or use different
parameter values.
And then you execute the
entire run as an experiment,
and it's this repeatable and
reusable training pipeline
that lets you run
multiple iterations
and actually produce
different models to compare.
And though each pipeline here
may develop one or actually
many models, the
output of this process
is not a model to
deploy, but rather
the code of the pipelines
and its components
which is source controlled
and control repository.
Then similar to any
software system,
you set up a CI/CD
process for your code,
including building components,
running automated tests,
and tagging all the
produced artifacts.
Those produced artifacts, like
compile packages and container
images, are stored in a
central artifact store.
And then the
pipeline is deployed
to a target environment.
This can be a test or dev
environment, a pre product
staging environment, or
a production environment,
depending on the CI/CD trigger.
If this is a
production pipeline,
it is executed automatically
and repetitively to continuously
train your model
given new data that
can be either based
on a schedule,
like daily, weekly,
we mentioned,
or based on a specific
trigger, for example
the availability of
new data or a drop
in performance of
the model that's
actually running in production.
When a continuous training
pipeline runs until the end,
it outputs a newly
trained model,
and that is stored
in the central model
registry for deployment
as a prediction service
at some point in the future.
Crucially, the link between
the model artifact itself
and the training pipeline
is never severed,
meaning that all models
in the model registry
can tell you their provenance,
what pipeline trained them,
who created the model, who ran
the training job, what data it
was trained on and
evaluated on, what
were the metrics and results
of the different evaluations.
This lineage tracking
is incredibly key,
as we'll see in the future.
One additional thing
to highlight here--
you'll notice the parity
between the dev and experiment
pipeline on the top row here,
and the continuous production
pipeline on the bottom row here.
Avoiding the dev and
production inconsistency
is crucial, as it's
the source of many bugs
or underperformance of
models and production,
and is really hard to
debug for most teams.
So now that we have an overview
of the reliable and repeatable
training pipeline,
which again, is
the foundational
first step of MLOps,
let's take a look at
the serving pipeline.
For deploying the
trained model, we'll
want to execute model serving
as a CI/CD process as well.
So you'll fetch
the model artifacts
from the model registry where
our training pipelines have
actually stored
them, as we just saw,
along with the code that
wraps the model as a service,
for example, as a REST API, to
execute the following steps.
First, building the prediction
service itself, then
running tests, which
may and probably
should be unique to your
use case and organization.
And then deploying the service
to the target environment
or environments.
And it's during this
point in the process
where it's often advisable
to run additional tests
and add some release gates.
So for an online
serving use case,
you may want to canary your
model on production hardware
to ensure that it meets
certain latency requirements.
You might actually also want
to test out different hardware
to make sure you're deploying
the model to the appropriately
optimal hardware for
that model architecture.
In addition, you might want
to run organized A/B tests
to ensure that your new
candidate model truly
outperforms the current
model in production
before routing all of
your traffic to it,
and so you might take
1% or 5% of your traffic
and send it to the new model
to test out how it's performing
on true production data.
For that, you'll also need to
capture the eventual business
outcome to serve
as the ground truth
in evaluating that
model's performance.
When the model is deployed
in the serving infrastructure
itself, it starts to serve
prediction on live data,
and you can then enable
explainability and continuous
evaluation where the serving
logs are captured and stored
for monitoring and
analysis in the future.
We monitor model
performance and production
to know if models
are going stale,
to identify if
there's any outliers
or if there's skew or concept
drift exhibited in the data.
This would be something like
the statistical properties
of the data changing
over time, which
can trigger a new
iteration of model training
or experimentation, and
this happens all the time.
We know we live in
a dynamic world,
and the data is constantly
shifting around underneath us.
And so it's incredibly
key to keep a close watch
on the production
data that's coming in,
so we can identify, for example,
if a particular class is
seeing a shift in its
underlying distribution.
Again, crucially, because
we have maintained
model provenance and
lineage like we mentioned,
we can use a model's
offline performance
as a baseline when
comparing against production
and quickly identify where
concept drift has occurred
as live data shifts away
from the training data.
This also lets data science
teams quickly pull up
the training data and
pipeline to reproduce the run,
figure out where the
issue might be occurring,
and then debug things.
Taking a step back
and zooming out,
here's the end to end
view of both training
and serving using
our MLOps framework--
a map to the input output
artifacts and different storage
systems.
So we start again
with experimentation
and development,
where we develop
a training pipeline that
is reusable and repeatable.
And then the code is checked
into a code repository
for source control.
We then build that training
pipeline and deploy it
to the target environment,
either to staging
or production, using
a CI/CD process,
where the artifacts
are registered
in the central artifact
repository, where
we can pull out those
artifacts for deployment
or roll back in the future.
Now, the pipeline is
running in production,
we can do continuous
training, either
on a weekly or
daily basis, or when
we have a particular
trigger based
on the model running
in production
or new data is available.
The outputs of these are
stored in the model registry,
which can be picked
up for a model CI/CD
process in the future.
That model CI/CD
process includes
all of the tests, stage
gates, and approvals
necessary to
rigorously make sure
that the model you're deploying
in production is ready
and is actually outperforming
the model that is currently
in production.
And then crucially, when
that model is actually
running on production
hardware, we
want to make sure that
it's constantly staying up
to performance
metrics and that we
can identify when it's
starting to decay over time,
or whether there's skew or drift
so we can go back to an earlier
step in this process,
retrain new models,
and deploy them in
production for testing.
In addition, this is a very
complex and high volume process
where customers may be running
thousands of different training
experiments for
a single use case
and testing dozens of
different models in production
at any given time.
And it's important that we make
sure we get this full picture
and make it available
to our teams.
And so each of our pipelines
and steps in this MLOps process
writes out key
executions and artifacts
to a central metadata store
where ML teams, IT leaders,
and governance folks have a
system of record where they
can do analysis or run
an audit to keep track
of these myriad processes
ongoing as we automate
the different steps
of our assembly line
from machine
learning [INAUDIBLE]..
Now that we have this
big picture view,
and we've put it all together,
let's talk about MLOps on who
Google Cloud's AI platform.
We'll discuss some of the
products and components
that we offer to
enable such a system,
and as mentioned the
Cloud AMP platform really
is our suite of integrated
products for building and using
AI.
And here, we'll just take
a focus on [INAUDIBLE]..
Then we'll provide
a bit more context
on the relevant individual
products themselves.
So like before, let's
start with a team
that has existing data and
products and clear use cases.
They may be running
analysis and experiments
locally or in different
siloed environments
for different organizations.
This is what data science looked
like sometime around 2010.
There's a lot of
ad hoc analysis,
a lot of custom tooling, a lot
of different experiments run
locally.
Not a lot of cloud usage.
Laptops stored a lot of the
knowledge of data scientists
and organization, and when
they left the organization,
that knowledge was largely lost.
The first thing teams
usually standardize on
from this original view is the
core data science platform.
This would be things like
which language they should use,
which frameworks they'll use,
the preferred development
environments, all of
the different things
that most of the team members
will probably argue about.
In 2020, the average
data science team
at most organizations has a
pretty good handle on this,
and though there are
many different options
to choose from, and there
are different benefits
and challenges associated
with those different options,
and also there's a lot of low
hanging fruit for improvement
here, enterprises are
still better positioned
than they were five years
ago from a core data science
tooling standpoint and
model building standpoint.
Harkening back to our
introductory section
and our framework, what most
teams are now moving to build
is this true production
grade platform for MLOps.
These are the services that
enable the end to end workflow
that we saw before following
our MLOps framework--
experimentation, continuous
training, model CI/CD,
and continuous monitoring.
And so let's take a
look at what this looks
like for specific GCP products.
At the data science layer, we
have our AI platform notebooks,
which is a hosted Jupyter
lab environment integrated
with our infrastructure
and various services.
You can connect to a source
control system, run notebooks
in a scheduled manner,
and you have control
over the underlying compute.
This is a familiar interface
for data scientists who
like to do ad hoc development
using Jupyter notebooks,
especially the upfront
part of their prototype
and experimentation phase.
In the MLOps and
infrastructure layer,
we've built this on modular
services backed largely
by open source, and mostly by
open source created by Google.
Each of the boxes
here can be used
to varying degrees,
or none at all
depending on your
different needs.
Based on many of the
internal expertise
we have and working with
many of our customers,
we know that AI workloads
can be highly customized,
and so our services are designed
for novice, intermediate,
and advanced machine learning
teams to use whatever they need
and also bring their own tools
to the platform, as well.
It's the core of this MLOps
layer lives our AI platform
training and
prediction services,
which are the backbone of
building and running models.
The items in green
are where we're
making our latest investments--
a feature store to help solve
training serving skew issues
and improved collaboration
within teams.
By registering features during
the upfront training process,
you can ensure that
those same features
are available in production
for your model at low latency.
And you can also share those
features with other team
members to ensure that all teams
have access to the great work
that individual data
scientists are doing
and make sure we're
not duplicating effort,
and we're using the most
powerful and effective features
to build new models.
In addition, a robust
experiment tracking service
to enable large scale
experimentation--
the ML model introspection
use case and comparison
incorporating great Google
open source products
like TensorBoard.
This is also really
critical because the amount
of experiments we
run is directly
proportional to how confident
we are that we've really
chosen the best model.
By making experiments shareable
and easily referenceable
in the future, we can
then enable other members
of our team working on the
same or similar use cases
to learn from the
work that we've
done in generating the optimal
model for our use case.
At the bottom layer there,
we have our ML pipelines
and centralized metadata store
for orchestrated managed end
to end workflows.
These are really critical
for building this end
to end capability and making
sure we're not writing custom
code for different
steps of this end
to end process that can't
be leveraged and reused
in the future.
We want to make sure we're
orchestrating full runs of end
to end pipelines and tracking
the outputs of each step,
the inputs and
outputs of each step,
in our central metadata store.
And for many of these
different items in green,
we offer great open source
and hosted solutions today,
and we're working on
bringing managed services
to these areas in 2020.
And so what's shown here is
simply the high level overview
focused on our MLOps stack.
Definitely stay tuned
for announcements
in these investment
areas and more
as our platform grows
in breadth and depth.
And so with that, I'll leave
you with this view of our MLOps
platform.
Your teams can begin
leveraging the power of MLOps
on GCP immediately by checking
out our AI platform in the GCP
console.
For more information, I've
included some detailed blogs
and solution guides for
further reading, which
are the best place
to start here,
and they'll be
published alongside
this breakout session.
After reading these, please
reach out to your Google Cloud
rep to get in touch.
He would absolutely
love to hear from you.
We'll also be answering
your questions in the Dory
throughout the next week or so.
I thank you for tuning
in and listening,
and we are immensely excited
to see what you build
with our Cloud AI platform.
Thank you.